we're going to talk about try perfect
numbers try perfect numbers we've heard
of perfect numbers having wait we've
done that on numberphile before if one
of our first ones wasn't it I think we
need to do a quick recap of what a
perfect number is because that's going
to be relevant to what a try perfect
number is so a perfect number is a
number like six six is a perfect number
and that's because factors of 6 are 1 2
3 and 6 itself in fact what we're going
to do we're going to ignore the number
itself if we add up the other factors so
we'll have 1 plus 2 Plus 3 we're going
to end up with the original number we're
going to have 6 the next perfect number
is 28 and it works the same way if you
look at the factors of 28 and add them
up you'll get the original number the
next one is going to be 496 that's a
perfect number the next one after that
is 8,000 128 and they keep going right
so those are quite rare we think there's
infinitely many of them but we found 50
so far the largest one we found is the
most recent which is a perfect number
that is 46 million digits long so we do
think there's infinitely many of them
although we haven't proven that to be
true and all the perfect numbers we
found are even we haven't found an odd
perfect number yet so that's something
that hasn't been proven yet but this
definition I gave you was kind of weird
because I ignored the number itself so I
said out of all the factors except the
number itself you could just add all the
factors including the number itself
that's perfectly fine and then you could
say a perfect number is you add up all
the factors and you get double the
original number that's absolutely fine
what happens if we add up all the
factors and get triple the number that
is a tri perfect number well the
smallest tri perfect number is 120 if we
look at the factors of 120 you have 1 2
3 4 5 6 8 10 12 15 20 is a factor
for 30 40 60 and will include 120 itself
so those are the factors of 120 and if
you add them up you will get 360 you
will get 3 times the original number so
that is the first try perfect number let
me write out the next few let's start a
list here with 120 and the next one is
672 the next try perfect number after
that is 520 3776 the next one after that
is 459 million eight hundred and
eighteen thousand 240 the next one after
that is 1 billion 476 million three
hundred and four thousand eight hundred
and ninety-six and the next one that I
might put this one in I'll put it here
51 billion and 1 million hundred and
eighty thousand one hundred and sixty so
I've got six they're written out and
that's all of them that's all we know
and we also think that's a complete list
we think there's finitely many of them
we think there's six of them only that
is a complete list there are six try
perfect numbers now that's not proven
but we really do believe that this is a
complete list couple of reasons for this
we have searched for them and we've
searched quite a long way we've searched
huge numbers like numbers that are 350
digits long like really big numbers but
they just stopped so we have a try
perfect number in the hundreds we have
try perfect numbers in the thousands we
have them in the millions we have them
in the billions and then they just stop
and it would be really weird if there
was a zip sums of massive try perfect
number so there's this massive massive
gap and then another try perfect number
suddenly appears that would be really
weird if that's true now we don't know
that this is a complete list but it
would be really weird if it wasn't a
come
meet list and there is other reasons why
we think this is complete list because
it's also related to perfect numbers
fact it's related to odd perfect numbers
if you remember I said we haven't found
any odd perfect numbers yet and there is
a relation between odd perfect numbers
and tri perfect numbers if you had a
number let's just call it n and if that
is odd perfect
then 2n is tri perfect so that means
that if we do find an odd perfect number
one day and it's going to be massive if
we ever find it if we find it one day
then automatically we're going to find a
new tri perfect number so either we're
going to find this odd perfect number
and this list is not complete after all
or this list is complete which means
that aren't any odd perfect numbers
which we also believe not proven but we
strongly believe that's true James I'm
glad you asked because yes absolutely so
there are four perfect numbers five
perfect numbers I show you them we can
look at them I've got them yeah and the
smallest four perfect number that we
know is thirty thousand two hundred and
forty so if you look at the factors of
that number and add them up you'll get
four times the original number there are
36 known for perfect numbers and then
the list of stops again and then we
can't find any more so we think again
we've got a finite list here and we
think we have all the four perfect
numbers you can take it a step further
of course look at five perfect numbers
the smallest five perfect number is 14
billion 182 million four hundred and
thirty nine thousand and forty there's
sixty five of those that we know of that
we found and again it's the same thing
it looks like it's a finite list because
we found 65 of them and then it just
stops and we can't find any more so we
think maths a finite list as well same
is true for six perfect numbers and
seven perfect numbers we think we found
a complete list then they just stop if
you love numbers and I think maybe you
do because you're here watching
numberphile then you really should check
out brilliant a site full of quizzes
puzzles courses all dedicated to
mathematics and science among them is
this course here on number theory it's
one of my favorites and you can see here
a few problems specifically about
perfect numbers brilliant is a treasure
trove of interactive content that's
gonna make you really love learning it's
good fun and makes you a bit smarter
along the way now there's a whole bunch
of stuff on the site for free but you
can also get 20% off brilliance Premium
Membership which gives you even more
stuff by going to brilliant org slash
numberphile that also tells brilliant
you came from here so that's good for
numberphile too
our thanks to them for supporting this
episode and I'll include in the
description some links to some excellent
stuff on brilliant you might wanna have
a look at
[Music]